we have 46 of Americans right now
self-identifying as Independence is that
because they are truly completely
independently minded and they don't want
to belong to anything with any sort of
label or is it that no one's invited to
them to a home that is inclusive and
makes them feel good right like what if
we built that home for them what if we
built a place that was Solutions
oriented that focused on compromise and
getting done
um what a notion and and I just I felt
that need so so desperately Andrew the
need for for a sense of community
broader sense of community amongst
Americans so when I saw what y'all were
doing uh last summer I thought huh
that's the other piece of the puzzle
[Music]
it is my pleasure and thrill to Welcome
to the podcast the newly named CEO of
the forward party Lindsay draft Lindsay
welcome hey Andrew thank you thank you
for having me of course it's been a lot
of fun working with you and getting to
know you these past weeks and months uh
and you're new to most people listening
to this so for most people listening to
this it'd be like oh
um forward party has a new CEO
um so you and I got to know each other
while you were a senior executive at
this awesome organization unite America
which yeah I mean the name kind of says
it all but what the heck is unite
America and what were you doing there so
unite America is a it's an organization
that actually functions as a pooled fund
to raise money and then invest in
structural reform campaigns uh across
the country and also to support
candidates so that's that's pretty
explicitly what it does but in a broader
sense United America sits in this big
space that people talk about Andrew is
democracy and I think oftentimes
especially because of some of the
challenges in the in the last two
election Cycles uh folks find that the
notion of democracy people think is
synonymous with voting rights and the
Voting Rights space is is critically
important um but also relatively well
funded there's a lot of leadership in
the Voting Rights space
um it's a it's an area that's been in
existence longer than the structural
reform space
um and certainly longer than the third
party so when we look at the work that
the team at United America did to invest
in a series of ballot reform measures
around the country it was pretty
significant because it's a it's a
relatively nascent and new and
underfunded space yes when you say a
structural reform uh what I think is
non-partisan primaries ranked Choice
voting which will be familiar to people
who are into to forward and those ballot
initiatives or campaigns require
resources and unite America is probably
the biggest source of funds for those
initiatives and you were yes and you
were front and center in trying to get
those resources in the door yeah we
raised from in 2019 when I joined the
team over there
um they had set forth a pretty ambitious
goal of raising and deploying 100
million dollars into the structural
reform space
um and we actually surpassed that goal
um through the 2022 election
um and we were able to do that because
of extraordinary philanthropists and and
supporters around the country who are
willing to make the investment but also
because of really worthy campaigns
um that showed us a Pathway to Victory
that um you know Not only would would we
have a pathway towards winning but that
win would result in something that was
really transformational and Alaska is a
great example of that so we were early
and consistent investors in the uh top
four primary system in Alaska which was
the combination of a non-partisan
primary and then ranked Choice voting
general election and we saw at the end
of 2022 the results of that
transformative
um reform and yeah and the re-election
of of Lisa murkowski and then the
election of the first ever you know
indigenous person Native Alaskan to
Congress beating Sarah Palin so really
really exciting stuff there Mary paltola
I love Mary Mary is awesome yeah so for
those of you who wonder how the heck any
of that came about uh Lindsay in United
America were working on that ballot
initiative before it was cool uh back in
2020. we're cool now we are so hip and
relevant Andrew and then and then also
in Nevada uh unite America was behind a
lot of the resources there and the
Nevada ballot initiative people if you
did dig into it I think the the total uh
deployment was about 17 million dollars
um so Lindsay was instrumental in
growing that space really from what do
you think it it was when you got there
in 2019
um gosh I'd say I think we were
like seven million
yeah so so that's a lot of growth so
what the heck kind of case did you make
to people when you were like Hey guys
you're investing money in the wrong
things you should invest it over here
yeah I'll tell you so um you know 2020
presented a really um exciting
opportunity for the reform space
um our friends Catherine Gail and
Michael Porter had released a book
called the politics industry where they
started to kind of socialize the notion
of final five voting understanding the
difference between open primaries and a
singular non-partisan primary
um our friend Rob Richie over at Fair
vote has been doing this work for 30
years he just celebrated his 30th
Anniversary talk about doing it before
it was cool man you know and I think
sadly sadly for our nation Andrew but
but fortunately for this movement I
think things were just so broken things
were so very broken but that by the time
the 2020 election was ramping up you had
folks really looking at these reforms as
an opportunity to address
um a system that just was not
representative uh for the voters and was
not holding elected officials
accountable
um and wasn't inspiring them to do their
best work right as elected officials so
so you had this need so you had a
desperate need in the marketplace and
then you had a solution and you had
folks like Rob and Catherine who had
been doing this work so that the um
there was a little bit of there was a
little bit of seating there so you had
Massachusetts there was a ranked Choice
voting initiative unfortunately that
failed in Massachusetts but was endorsed
by the Boston Globe you had the ranked
Choice voting I think you're you're a
little familiar with the ranked Choice
voting in the in the Democratic primary
and in New York Andrew yep so so that
had passed um and you've got guys like
there there's a guy named Stan Lockhart
in Utah who has passed dozens of
Municipal initiatives adopting ranked
Choice voting in Utah so so you started
to see these different opportunities
really really clicking across the
country at the same time you saw a lot
of people wanting to try and invest in
something that was sticky Solutions
oriented and made a difference and I
think that these these Suite of reforms
it is a sweet you know not every state
or town is is going to respond in the
same way uh we're not a silver bullet
unite America wasn't a silver bullet
organization neither is the forward
party and so I think that that
combination of need resonance
um and uh
and funding all kind of came together uh
the United America ended up doing 30
they spent 33 million dollars between
2019 and 2020.
yeah it's great stuff and great growth
that you were an enormous part of so
what then Drew dad shout out to their
executive director Nick troiano who just
yeah so he's just he's a month he's just
a monster he worked so hard with his
heart in the right place so that's
that's
um you know you have leadership too in
the movement I mean leadership you know
with people like you and with Nick who
get in there and do the work every day
is really critical yeah Nick Nick's
tremendous so what Drew you over to this
side of the movement uh you know because
Ford party
um I'm super excited about uh the the
progress we've made but it is a
different approach and I I think uh in
some ways uh I think the reform
cause that you were championing and love
unite America love the work they're
doing
um it's like a slightly different
approach I'd say than what forward party
is doing I'll speak for myself for a
moment I I think that uh America is
getting polarized and torn apart uh by
these two warring tribes that uh and
like many Americans look at and don't
even recognize even if they might even
technically be a part of one of the
other
and preaching to the choir Andrew yeah
uh and so I thought okay
um we need to turn down the tribalism
turn down the polarization or else it's
going to wind up with uh literal
catastrophe uh and so I saw this group
of reforms as Mission critical but I
also thought that you needed to raise a
popular movement that Americans could
join and see themselves in that stood
for values of uh
being agreeable like knowing that uh
you're not going to agree on everything
under the sun in terms of issue position
uh that were all Americans we can
um
sit down and Hammer out Solutions where
we're all a little bit sad at the end
but that that's actually vastly Superior
to me just posturing and turning people
uh you know like uh on or off
emotionally uh in a way that ends up
dehumanizing people I mean now uh half
of Democrats view Republicans as corrupt
and a threat to the country uh and half
of Republicans feel the same way about
Democrats I mean that's not an
environment where anyone's going to be
able to get anything done and so I I
thought it was necessary to change the
dynamic and create a new unifying
positive popular movement
that could help bring people together
and also make the case for these reforms
so that was my approach to all of this
uh but but you have like a really
distinct Journey so like what was your
uh progression or line of thinking
yeah I I do have a distinct Journey
although you know I mean so many of us I
love hearing from our state leads around
the country what their light bulb moment
was that moment that that brought them
here what's inspired them uh to be
evangelists on behalf of this Mission it
really everybody comes to this space
um on their own Journey for me I had the
opportunity as I said to start to work
with United America in 2019 my
background was in Republican Party
politics Andrew so I'd spent I worked
for John Boehner I worked for the Romney
campaign as I um you and I were chatting
about our mutual friend Michael Steele
that was actually my first on the ground
full-time campaign that I did when he
ran for the United States Senate you
know after 2016
um it just never felt like the the party
that I had been a part of for so many
years for many people in this space uh
you know the anti-trump factor is is
part of their Journey it actually wasn't
for me because I always saw Donald Trump
as a as a symptom of something deeply
systemic in our nation it wasn't him it
was the fact that people were drawn to
him and understanding what is happening
right now in our nation that someone
who's vitriol is resonating to a point a
place where you know the language and
the and the tone
um that he espoused that folks would
never allow for in their own homes right
or amongst their friends or their
colleagues or in front of their children
they were creating allowances for us he
normalized a lot of very very
immortalized it it was really bizarre
and so I I didn't look at it as him I
looked at it as a bigger systemic issue
and and so what what I found is
um you know in in my work in Republican
Party politics uh I I found some really
good people that I really thought were
drawn
um to elected office into service with a
servant mindset who all of a sudden were
running as close to Donald Trump as they
could and it just
it was it was bizarre yeah that is
bizarre but it's like pod people like
zombie apocalypse like they had been
bitten or something right they couldn't
help themselves so I I was lucky enough
to to
um have an opportunity to start working
with unite America and you know shared
with the people that I worked with there
that I finally found a home I felt like
I had um you know been politically
homeless and found a home
still um registered Republican
that was my option right but I felt like
I was helping to Advocate um for the
adoption of these really transformative
uh reforms
uh that would release people from that
that two-party grip
um at least the elected officials who
maybe had to come are a common D didn't
you know didn't have to caucus with them
and they would be free to work across
the aisle all things that are true all
things that are true it is plumbing
plumbing is important anybody who's a
homeowner who has water issues knows how
important Plumbing is so Plumbing is
important but um you know Plumbing isn't
what you know brings people together
with families over the holidays around a
shared table right like a home is more
than Plumbing it's it's a place of
gathering and it's a place of belonging
and it's a place of community and
um what I realized in um in the adoption
of these reforms or rather I would say
for you know the the campaigning for for
these reforms uh that there weren't
enough people around and we had really
really well-intentioned very smart
people right like the Democracy reform
space and and the adoption of structural
reforms in in the whole Suite right like
Fusion voting star voting approval
voting nonpartisan primaries open
primaries very smart people
um pretty academic right pretty wonky
maybe not necessarily tapping into those
deep senses of um of of feeling and a
need for belonging
um lamenting where our nation was headed
what we were leaving to our children
um hard to make that connection
um and so I realized that I thought that
you know I realized my thinking was that
we needed a parallel track yeah Plumbing
is critical we have to have the plumbing
and we have to fix the plumbing but we
have to have a parallel track to create
a home for Americans to tap into that
passion we have 46 of Americans right
now self-identifying as Independence is
that because they are truly completely
independently minded and they don't want
to belong to anything with any sort of
label or is it that no one's invited to
them to a home that is inclusive and
makes them feel good right like what if
we built that home for them what if we
built a place that was Solutions
oriented that focused on compromise and
getting done what a notion and then
those people together would demand for
updates in our Plumbing Systems then you
start to see real catalytic change
demand for the Plumbing Systems
implementation of the Plumbing Systems
and then people who are involved and
holding folks accountable that's how
we're going to see change
um and and I just I felt that need so so
desperately Andrew the need for for a
sense of community broader sense of
community amongst Americans so when I
saw what y'all were doing uh last summer
I thought huh I think that's the other
piece of the puzzle
thank you
I've always been a mattress guy it's one
reason I'm so thrilled that this podcast
is sponsored by Helix sleep Helix sleep
is the future of mattresses you take the
Helix sleep quiz at their website and
get your perfect mattress fit in under
two minutes it takes a little longer for
them to get that to your door but when
they send it to your door you get a
hundred night free trial I know it's
crazy that's over three months and then
over a 10 year warranty to try out your
new Helix mattress it's become the go-to
mattress for my kids in the house and
they have a few mattresses to choose
from but they just always seem to find
this one you don't need to take my kids
word for it it's also the number one
mattress pick by wired GQ imagine that
job just trying out mattresses for
magazines but it's number one and it's
number one for a reason Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix bittersleep
Starts Now
[Music]
foreign
we are the other piece of the puzzle and
now you were going to be leading the
charge so super excited yeah I think the
press the press release went out today
so I think now it's official so no
backing out now yeah well you've already
been a part of the org for uh the last
couple of months and we'll talk about
what your experience has been
um but I I want to refer back to what
you talked about in 2016 when you saw a
bunch of folks that you'd seen
um as being motivated by the Right
Things become pod people or whatnot uh
like that there was an experience for
for a lot of folks uh during that point
when Trump took over the Republican
party and you were plugged into a lot of
those organizations and you were like no
thank you but a lot of other people said
uh I guess this is what we're doing now
I just went that direction so what the
heck was that experience like and and
did you have to go against the current
or the grain um and we've had a couple
of people who are part of Ford who left
the Republican party who paid a deep
professional cost oh yeah oh yeah I am I
cannot stress enough how blessed I am to
have found this home
um first of all as an American as a
um as a wife as a mother
um personally really really grateful but
professionally for those of us who are
career politicos
um it's you know you people have
mortgages people have lives that's you
know that's been their career path
um and you know not unlike any
um industry that goes Belly Up
um you know you lose your job so do you
cling to that do you you know do you
kind of cling to the capsized life raft
and and try and hold on
um I I didn't want to anymore
um wasn't worth it to me so I'm really
grateful to be here I will say I think
that I spent you know I spent a long
time
in politics and my my colleagues and my
friends have have remained so they've
been really supportive of me
um I I received a number of fair
warnings you know you can't come back
Lindsay you're going to want to come
back I said to what
what am I going to go about what would I
come back to that's very strong let's
say that the forward party one of the
things that I think that we can
accomplish is actually forcing the
existing two-party structure to behave
better right like if we can force them
to behave better
I think that's extraordinary to have a
competitive you know three competitive
parties in the United States how great
for us as Americans and citizens
um but what is that a decade that you
know that would be a decade in the
making and again it requires a
competitive new party to force their
hand
um so I I left I don't I have I have
zero regrets I have nothing but
gratitude
um but as as folks who make their career
in in politics it's tough
yeah I had Kate on a few months ago and
she talked about the same thing she had
to make the same Choice and then they
would be like it's a one-way Street
they really try and
um you know put the fear in
um though you know the water is fine on
the other side
um though it's fine because of people
like you and Kate who are uh making
principled patriotic decisions that may
or may not you know be like the
um best moves to your bank account in
like a short term or you know and I
gotta tell you it
such a wonderfully diverse group of
professionals at headquarters right now
it really is I mean it's it is so
representative of a variety of of
different professional backgrounds
um you know uh certainly political
affiliations you mentioned Kate she and
I do not see items a lot of things
except for the fact that we're committed
to a solution and we're committed to
compromise and getting there
um and that that means that we get to
run in the same direction every day and
it's just it's a joy yeah they're
they're great people and one thing I do
want to note is that uh Kate Sayer Matt
schinner's Miles Taylor
um like uh Joel Sierra be like the folks
that people think of as part of forward
party will Conway
um you know that they've all been
working with you for the last couple of
months already because you joined as the
head of Engagement uh and then you know
we had a CEO search going concurrently
and and concluded uh that you were the
best fit in part because we had already
seen you in action
um what's your experience been like
working with the team and meeting with
State leads and volunteers and activists
around the country yeah the team
again I mean I mean match Jenners who
has been functioning as the interim CEO
has some sort of like magic power
you all took three Legacy organizations
and merged not just staff but staff with
different philosophies they all came to
the work for different reasons and
different motivations to a certain
extent I think their their solution to
fixing the problem was slightly
different
um and he was able to bring all of those
people together
um and and get folks Marching In The
Same Direction which is just you know
anyone in Corporate America who's LED
mergers uh is an extraordinary feat and
I just give Matt a like so much credit
for that he's he's an extraordinary
human being
um and so uh I think and Matt's still
here Matt's not going anywhere just so
he's not going anywhere that's not going
anywhere he's not allowed to he can take
a break but a short break
he knows that
um you know I think that uh you know you
have folks again from from from varying
different professional backgrounds too
so just kind of norms around work and
things like that how I mean like I'm I'm
just like a DC swamp monster like hard
and Politico so my work style is going
to be different than other lovely
members of our team that's a funny
self-characterization Lizzy that wasn't
if it in the press release or my
description of you yeah I know we should
we welcome heart and swap creature
Lizzie draft
no you know I mean first of all anybody
who's ever worked with me knows that I I
probably cry three times a day I'm just
I'm I'm so my heart is so filled with
this work and this Mission
um and that and and I share that with
every single person so regardless of
where folks have come everybody is just
so filled with conviction and passion as
relates to the work
um so that that has been an
extraordinary finding of mine and um and
those are amongst the people who are
paid then we go out into the states
where we have hundreds of volunteers and
in my first month I had the pleasure of
actually hitting five different markets
meeting the people who are doing this
work on the ground as volunteers and uh
coming at this just again people coming
to this having their had their light
bulb moments for so many different
reasons
um and coming together and creating real
compelling infrastructure like this is
not everybody's sitting around and like
eating bon bons like I go into these
meetings and folks are at boardrooms
they're putting together bylaws they
have Finance plans they are driving
toward um you know their Signature
Collection campaigns for ballot access
um and not a single one of them in the
room
from what I've seen has any sort of
political background and they are doing
this bringing their experiences and
talents to the table
um and sharing you know what people
bring in terms of their own kind of
individual superpowers to inform the
work and it's um it's just aw inspiring
it really is it's very very cool
foreign
if you know me you know that I think
that our data should be ours and that
big Tech right now is running roughshod
on our autonomy our agency our privacy
for sure one way to help turn the tables
on big Tech is to use expressvpn like I
do when I surf the web it keeps you
private by piping you in to another IP
address it's what big companies use it
was rated the number one VPN that's
virtual private Network by CNET wired
and more let's take it back from Big
Tech Stop handing over your personal
data to the quasi-monopolies that mine
our activity and sell our info for their
profit not ours protect yourself with a
VPN I trust to keep me and mine safe
online visit expressvpn.com Yang that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com to get three extra
months free
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
hey I've had the same experience one one
state I visited recently was South
Carolina and I had people use themselves
just to give a sense and when Eisenhower
shout out yeah Clinton Eisenhower was
great 60 to 65 of the people in the room
were either military veteran there was a
retired Colonel there it was freaking
awesome but either military veteran
military family uh or from some kind of
uh service background and that really
blew me away uh listening to this where
someone would say you know like hey I'm
heading to service like you know like I
uh served for years and years
um that there's been
one there had been a number of
consistent uh backgrounds but that that
one really hit me hard in South Carolina
in Arizona
um it was uh really equally awesome
people uh there was like a an attorney
who just figured all this out and was
like thank goodness that now we're we're
doing it
there was a guy who worked in municipal
government for 20 years and and just
said you know like I he was a civil
engineer and he's like I just like to
solve problems and this is the biggest
problem I've I've seen
um so the the folks who are drawn to the
forward party in states around the
country are just awesome really really
uh
Civic uh minded Patriots and and I will
say that everyone's there for the right
reasons but you know that there's no one
who comes to it for sort of like the the
there's no room for there's no
room for you know I think one
of the things that um resonates with me
Andrew when you talk about the
engagement of the veterans community
um you know I was on the on the phone
with Todd Connor who's over at Veterans
for political Innovation just a great
group great group and um and we shared
something that we have in common which
is that the get done mentality
um you know for for veterans looking at
this space it's like no we just have to
create a plan and get after it like
let's just get this done we're going to
this actually okay
totally action oriented
um which I just I love so they're
they're extraordinary partners for all
of us in the space yeah so uh to retrace
your steps a little bit you showed up to
DC as a college student uh yeah yeah and
and then you got involved on Capitol
Hill
um uh in different capacities were you
someone who showed up to DC thinking hey
I'm gonna get into politics and make the
world a better place like what was the
original thinking yes to the former
Community actually my senior year of
high school I got to live abroad and
um definitely shifted my perspective
um you know more globally and
um and then I had an opportunity to do
some some really cool travel uh when I
was in college
um actually
um it was it was a blessing but but a
unfortunate circumstance that I was
there I actually went and was deployed
as part of an earthquake relief team uh
in 1999 uh when earthquakes hit Turkey
um so watching the news right now is is
terrible just is crushing
um having been on the ground
um then 25 years ago and watching what
those people went through so I I
definitely had more of kind of a Global
Perspective and then I went from Global
to hyper local when I came home one
summer I had Mono I was not supposed to
be uh in Connecticut that summer I got
mono and I got a job working for the
Town Clerk and I went to town hall every
day and I work for the Town Clerk and I
registered dogs
and then when folks came in and needed
printouts of their uh their plots of
their their property lines I had this
giant coffee machine and I would roll
the whole thing through and the town
clerk in Connecticut was the one named a
woman named Claudia Weber and uh Claudia
changed my life
she cared she cared about her community
she knew everybody in town she loved
being the town clerk she'd gone to GW
and had great stories of
um all sorts of wild things that she had
done in Washington and all sorts of like
crazy aspirational roles she could have
had and she came home and she worked as
a town clerk in Connecticut and Claudia
um put a couple phone calls in for me
and got me an internship working for a
guy named Chris Chase who is a
representative of Connecticut for
extraordinarily thoughtful bipartisan
leader in the House of Representatives
which is why he lost
um re-election but really really good
guy and it was I got an internship on
Capitol Hill and it was just magic like
interns back then and I don't this was
before 9 11 so I don't know if it exists
anymore but we had a pass to the Library
of Congress so like where other kids
went to school and researched their
papers on campus at the library which we
had a great Library like I went to the
library at Congress and I had the
Librarians help me research and pull
stuff it was just it was just a magical
key to something remarkable
um so that was yeah those are Claudia
Weber at the town clerk I registered
docs that was my first job in politics
wow and then uh you climbed the ranks uh
in Capitol Hill in various ways worked
for our friend Michael Steele I did when
he had the kind of the this
um internal Revolution over at the RNC
and and then you started and ran your
own business for years and years yeah
very successfully which I I think is
such a feat as someone who started and
run a couple of organizations like any
anyone who actually has done that uh
successfully uh you know like the buck
stops at you there's like no place
elsewhere to go oh yeah
business partner and I were
payroll you're like okay
yeah yeah there's no place to go no one
to blame
yeah you feel like the head of an
extended family and you know near the
actual head of like a you know like a a
real family
um you know you were the parent of three
I want to say yeah I've got three we
have um our big girl is 12 and we have
eight-year-old twins they'll be nine
next month wow twins expected
oh my God Andrew I'll tell you so I was
um so we had just launched our company
we were
um we were about a year we were about a
year in not quite a year in and things
were starting to cook and we were we
were super stoked we were starting to
sign you sign big clients and um really
one of my big big anchor clients was
um Speaker Boehner so uh I was his
National finance committee consultant
and worked to build out a national
finance committee for the speaker which
was so much fun because it was actually
him coming in and working with
delegations in the states bringing
together members house members
Republican house members in various
States
um uh to raise money so it was really
fun because I got to know a lot of the
members really well
um and I found out I was partnering with
the twins and I had like three or four
fundraisers flanking my delivery date
and one of them required me to go up to
New York and I had a big meeting at KKR
Ken mellman General Petraeus and all
these like very important speaker of the
house and I am seven and a half months
pregnant with twins and one of two women
in that board room and I kind of waddled
in
everyone went oh God don't mess with her
so uh yeah I was uh it was not they were
not expected and I was not uh there was
no way I was going to relinquish uh my
work on that particular project so
thank you
so you've been plugged into a bunch of
uh folks who were senior in the
Republican Party 2016 you think okay
guys this is not the way and then a
bunch of them struggling to be like I
guess this is the way though I'm sure a
few few of them surreptitiously you said
to you like oh I don't I don't like
what's going on uh like what where where
do you think that group is now
um because I because I'm sure you talk
to people of of uh different backgrounds
and uh you've been talking to them about
structural reform for the last several
years yeah uh yeah because one of the
things that you said to me at some point
was like look I'm not sure if people
were ready uh you know four or five
years ago but they're increasingly ready
now I I stand by that in fact I met with
um some of our wonderful Legacy leaders
from Sam you know I sat down with them
in the spring of 2017 and I said look
I'm nervous we're all nervous we don't
know what we're in for here
um but I think that the predominant
um positioning amongst center right
Republicans is going to be to wait and
see
um you know let's not upset the apple
cart
um you know we still have
Mitch McConnell who we can trust we have
Paul Ryan who we can trust so let's not
upset the apple cart let's keep going
um and I don't think that folks are
ready at that time
um I do think this is different I think
it's much different right now and
um we it's just not getting better right
I can't say it is really right it's just
not getting better and I you know
um I am uh I'm an I'm an optimist but
I'm also a pragmatist and you know
there's a colleague of ours in the space
who she and I were on a panel together
last summer and she kept saying that you
know bye
talking about fixing the system the
notion of fixing the system and
introducing two-party a new party uh
Were Somehow undermining the system as a
whole and instead what we need to be
doing is reinforcing confidence in the
system and building out moderate
factions
and I just said too late it's too late
people have been trying to do that uh
for years and now they're throwing in
the towel I mean I've had a lot of those
conversations heck the entire renew
America movement crew was like we're
gonna restore the Republican party and
then they join the merger because they
said you know what like the Republican
party is lost yeah I just I don't think
that it's an option anymore Andrew I
think it's just way too far gone people
have figured out that they can vent like
their negative impulses and control the
party in a particular way and it's very
hard to put that Genie back in the
bottle you know like they've learned
that lesson
well and it's one thing too I think for
folks who
um have visions of of building out
moderate factions within the existing
party structures have never been to a
State Central Committee meeting they
have never been at a platform committee
meeting you know these aren't center
right center left leaders the the
leadership of of the party structures
are the extremes themselves and they are
going to continue to drive uh party
regulations and party rulings in a way
that incentivizes uh extremism so you
know I don't I think that folks who
think of themselves as you know a
center-left you know democrat or
center-right republican
um would be shocked to hear some of the
rhetoric that is coming out of
rulemaking committees in the current
two-party system they are not
representative of of the broad base of
Americans and where we want to go
they're incredibly divisive and um and
not and and they the bomb throwing and
the name calling
um of you know quote the other right
yeah yeah
this process of dehumanization yeah I I
I have no I I have no place there and it
is fun how people have come to forward
from different angles uh where like Matt
and Kate you know are are former Dems I
don't know if Matt was ever a Dem that's
been third party for a long time
[Laughter]
I've had enough policy conversations to
know that I know where he falls on a lot
of things it's great yeah yeah I was
like but at this point
um we're getting pitted against each
other in this like increasingly uh
destructive and and futile manufactured
conflict uh and so whatever goals we
might have for our country like we have
to say like look like this current
system is not going to serve them like
we have to no we have to upgrade
um and modernize the the system so
you've been working at forward for a
couple months and by the way you did a
bunch of things that
um I thought were awesome leadership
where you organized a retreat brought
everyone together like you know like got
like got everyone on the same page you
did a bunch of things I was like oh I
got that's some Aces leadership it's the
kind of thing that that I would have I
just wanted I just wanted to go to John
Kingston's form
I just I just wanted to see Snowy
snow-capped Mountains in Vermont no it
was um so important like culture I know
this is this is you know everyone said
but like culture eat strategy for
breakfast like it does all day long I
mean we can have the great greatest
strategic vision for party building and
if culturally we're all not synced and
there isn't you know a foundation of
trust amongst our team we'll never get
there
[Music]
which leads me to possibly the most fun
thing is like what what Liza lies ahead
what can we look forward to with a
forward party with Lindsay at its Helm
oh my gosh we're gonna be in your we're
gonna
we're in his backyards Andrew
we're so excited Kate Sayer has
envisioned um a forward together tour
and um it has kind of three components
one is going into a community and really
sit down with sitting down with
Community leaders understanding uh what
their needs are
um understanding where those needs are
being met by the two-party system how
they're being left behind
um we are looking for folks to
participate in those conversations uh
people who are leaders of all sorts of
different communities in various cities
across around the country so we just
started that process in Arizona we're
going to be out in California actually
this week I talked to the team in North
Carolina over the weekend we're going to
be in North Carolina doing it so that's
kind of the first component the second
component is a big large-scale event we
want folks to know we're here we want to
make a splash
um so we're going to make some noise
we're going to have some fun we're going
to recruit volunteers we're going to
raise a lot of money
um and then one of the things that's I
think really Central to a lot of the
folks who are drawn to this work is the
notion of service so how do we ensure
that communities understand that we're
there to serve them this isn't this
isn't a grift we're not trying to force
something down people's throats and to
that end if we're there how can we serve
the community so
um the other the other component of our
presence in these markets is partnering
with um local charities in service
projects so that Ford volunteers can be
out in the communities and helping um to
serve those who need it that's very
wholesome
beautiful Vision uh so the there is talk
of a convention
um this summer which might just include
some of the state leaders and activists
people ask me about it periodically do
you don't know where it's going to be
yeah so we are um so yes the notion of
our being having a presence in people's
communities and backyards and working
hand in hand in service projects is
wonderful
we also need to win we have to go out
there and win and that's where the
hardened political monster comes so
we're gonna get all of our state leads
together we are uh we are in the process
of signing a contract so I'm not going
to say where yeah
[Laughter]
Central located Place uh that's going to
be easy for everybody to get to
um close to an International Airport
we're gonna be there June 22nd through
the 25th
um and it's going to be an opportunity
for all of our state's leads to come
together
um and really talk about what it's going
to work what it's going to take to win
how are we going to build these parties
how are we going to create durable
lasting infrastructures how are we going
to initiate these Signature Collection
campaigns how are we going to recruit
candidates how are we going to run them
how are we going to raise money how are
we going to talk about it and get the
media to tell stories about it so we're
going to be doing all of that and then
um you know also again more team
building uh more um you know more kind
of imparting the culture and the values
and the principles of the Ford uh party
uh onto our onto our teams um you know a
little Kool-Aid drinking a little
Kool-Aid drinking is great we're going
to do that and so we're really excited
about that so June 22nd through the 25th
in a centrally
uh regionally central location
yeah no more to come stay tuned uh and
certainly I'm gonna block those dates
out so we had a national search for the
CEO we had Founders and CEOs of
organizations uh throw their hats in the
ring and it was really lovely in the
sense that uh there are a lot of people
I recognized the need for what we're
building
um but I I have to say Lindsay uh you
know the the team just was so blown away
by you and your uh leadership uh and
dedication from day one that we're so
pumped to have you as the new CEO you're
going to lead forward in a tremendous
growth path for the next number of years
I'm pumped to work alongside you do
everything I can to help but thank you
for your uh
your courage really I mean that you know
you were a very very experienced
Politico there are dozens of ways that
you could have uh gone that did not
involve trying to solve this set of
fundamental problems for the country but
you're here because uh you know this is
what the country needs so really on
behalf of everyone who loves forward
thank you and uh thank you I'm so
excited to work with you
thank you you know it is um it sounds
trite and easy it's just the right thing
right it's the right thing to do it's
the right place to be
in any movement in the history of our
nation there are the Misfits and the
outliers that that start the process and
and
um
and that's a little bit of where we are
right now
um but I believe in it I just I truly
truly believe in it it's the right thing
to do
um and I'm I'm really really grateful to
be here and for all the folks that are
on the journey with us because it's an
awesome group of people it is an awesome
group uh growing every day you know one
of the things let's see I sometimes ask
people it's like hey do you think the
solution is going to come from within
the Democratic party the Republican
party or other and then they think about
it for a second and they're like
definitely other and I'm like see like
you know
what I I didn't realize and I I guess I
slept on it that David Rubinstein has a
series that he does a peer-to-peer show
have you ever seen his show oh yeah yeah
he was on the podcast uh you know last
year I turned on um on Sunday he had um
Lorraine Powell jobs on yeah and she's
great and it was she's so great and it
was funny because you know talking to
her
um you know as an innovator and an
entrepreneur
um you know married to a disrupter she
is a disrupter and uh and you know David
Rubinstein kind of held up his cell
phone to her and said did you know like
did did your husband know did Steve know
that this was going to be the greatest
most transformational consumer product
ever
and she said no you know he always kind
of liked to think about himself is is
kind of you know the David against the
Goliath and a little Scrappy and I
thought hey
we can be the iPhone we can be the
iPhone of political parties why not I'll
tell you I'll I'll take it maybe we
could work with that Lindsay forward the
iPhone of political party sorry for you
non-apple users out there
including our our uh interim CEO uh Matt
shinners but it fits on a bumper sticker
right
it's it's all the good and gosh knows
that the country needs it and that
neither of the two parties resembles it
at all
no they don't they don't more Choice yes
as I say the backward party was taken
maybe twice all right Lindsay such a
pleasure and uh can't wait to get out on
the trail with you in the days to come I
will see you in California I'll see you
in California
[Music]
foreign